halak a beau ligne demeure par pierrette
s'entraîne avec le bouling club de
plaisir pierre était pensionnaire au
centre hospitalier de plaisir comme elle
des résidents au handicap différents
viennent tous les mercredis lancer les
boules de bowling
c'est très important pour eux ça leur
permet de se tourner vers l'extérieur et
des avoirs dont certaines activités
le bowling club de plaisir reçoit des
subventions de sa commune de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et du comité départemental des
yvelines pour permettre ce partenariat
avec le centre hospitalier
les ateliers ont lieu depuis 2018 ce
jour là il s'agit même d'un tournoi pour
jouer avec qui a brigué groupe avec des
groupes à ugo robin
[Musique]
chaque résident est accompagnée encadré
par un membre du club
ils sont quatre à faire tomber des
quilles chaque semaine ça permet de
mettre ces personnes qui souffrent de
handicap dans un environnement normal
l'association recherche d'autres
subventions vous faire perdurer son
action une manière de faire tomber les
préjugés sur le handicap